[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie you've
all probably seen the doctor strange to
announcement in the last day they
announced that scott derrickson the
director is actually leaving the project
and they're gonna bring on a different
director to do the movie we actually
have a lot of information about what
happened behind the scenes it's not as
sensational as people are making it out
to seem but there is a lot of stuff
going on behind the scenes so if you're
brand new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
it's only gonna get crazier later this
year and we're doing that big movie
ticket giveaway right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your predictions for Doctor
Strange to on the video you all probably
saw the headlines yesterday Marvel
announced that they were parting ways
with Scott Derrickson amicably over a
quote-unquote creative differences on
Doctor Strange - a little while after
Marvel made the official announcement in
the press Scott Derrickson went on his
Twitter account and basically said the
same thing like he still loves working
at Marvel he still loves all the Marvel
people but the movie that Marvel wanted
to make is not the movie that he wanted
to make we know a little bit more about
that there's actually some video clips
from back at Comic Con and then some
interviews with Kevin Feige it's a
little bit funny the way they talked
about Doctor Strange 2 separately here's
the clip of him talking about what he
envisioned the movie to be back at
comic-con you all probably remember this
I mean what excites me about Doctor
Strange is what made him great in the
comics that he doesn't fight villains
from this earth or even from this
universe but from the multiverse of
other dimensions so you get into all
kinds of psychedelic weirdness which
this movie is going to but when I came
and talked to Kevin about doing a sequel
I said I don't want to do just another
sequel to do a sequel if I'm gonna do it
it has to go into the territory that
drew me into the Doctor Strange comics
in the first place
which is how they dipped into the Gothic
and the horror and the and the horrific
and we're gonna make the first scary MCU
film
you can't you know you know why
no it's pg-13 you're gonna like it I'm
really excited to be at the dawn of this
project and I think it's vital to
maintain the integrity of humor and
stuff that we had in the first film but
with this twist of horror which I think
will really have people ger it so the
funny thing during that presentation is
these talks about making the first scary
MCU film a horror film then you heard
Kevin Feige quickly respond to someone
who was sitting in the front of the
crowd shouting up at the stage the
person he was responding to was asking
if because it's gonna be a horror film
if they were gonna make Doctor Strange
to rated-r because when you think big
horror films you typically think of the
rated-r horror films so that's why in
rapid succession after scott derrickson
the director in front of all those
comic-con people publicly because the
clip got posted all over the place was
seen by millions of people saying
they're gonna make a scary MCU movie the
person in the stage says rated-r Kevin
Feige says no it's gonna be pg-13 and
you're gonna love it so as you would
probably imagine the scuttlebutt is is
that because scott derrickson is
traditionally known is a full-blown
horror movie director by trade that's
how he landed on Marvel's radar
initially to direct the first Doctor
Strange movie that he wanted to make dr.
strange too
as a legit horror film and Marvel and
Kevin Feige just weren't on board for
that like no we want to make a big
action film with some scary sequences in
it but we don't want to make a super
weird traditional horror film like The
Nightmare on Elm Street dream warriors
with Marvel characters imagine dr.
strange Benedict Cumberbatch and Scarlet
Witch versus their version of Freddy
Krueger nightmare inside the MCU just
recently a little while ago there was
another clip of Kevin Feige that I
posted last week in a Doctor Strange
video where he was talking about a bunch
of Marvel phase 4 things he was talking
about how they're using Doctor Strange
to to introduce all this super weird new
cool stuff and new characters that fans
would never guess during that clip he
also talked about how his vision usually
aligned with directors most of the time
our visions align with directors which
is kind of funny because you think of
Edgar Wright leaving the ant-man project
after all this like oh this isn't the
first time that Marvel has had to part
ways with a director before a movie
started but during the clip when Kevin
Feige is talking about Doctor Strange to
being us
scary MCU movie he keeps referring to
Steven Spielberg's poltergeist as PG
horror and Indiana Jones Temple of Doom
like grabbing hearts from chests scary
pg-13 horror elements instead of what
you would think of is a traditional
rated R horror film like the first it
movie was a rated R horror film
Schank she's gonna be so much more than
a kung fu movie but if it has elements
of that which is we're excited about
multiverse of madness is the greatest
title we've ever come up with by the way
which is one thing that's exciting about
it and I wouldn't necessarily say that's
a horror film but it is as Scott
Derrickson our director has pitched it
it is it'll be a big MCU film with scary
sequences in it but that's fun it's fun
to be scared in that way and not a you
know horrific torturous way but in a way
that is legitimately scary cuz Scott
Derrickson is quite good at that but
scary in the service of an exhilarating
emotion so you have to imagine that
Kevin Feige is sitting in a room with
Scott Derrickson before the holidays say
yeah we're totally not gonna make
Nightmare on Elm Street dream warriors
with Marvel characters there were also
some posts that Scott Derrickson made to
his Twitter account before the holidays
that also kind of give you an idea for
where his headspace was that so he says
here the studio release dates are the
enemy of creativity so one of the other
reasons why he probably left the project
is is because he didn't feel like he
could make the movie that he wanted to
make that Marvel would also let him make
within the given amount of time that
they had before it comes out so the
release date isn't going to change when
they announced that Scott Derrickson was
leaving the project Marvel said that
there would be no delays they start
shooting the movie in May meaning the
Kevin Feige probably already has a
pretty good idea of who the new director
is going to come on to take over the
project the really good news and all
this is they're also still using the
same script that Scott Derrickson
and his writing partner came up with
they also worked on the script for the
first Doctor Strange movie so if you
like the way that that movie went down
you'll probably still enjoy what's going
on during Doctor Strange too and since
they're still using scott derrickson
version of the script that means that
all the villains all the characters that
he was going to introduce the plot isn't
going to change it's going to be all the
same stuff people are already joking
that they're gonna call the Russos to
come back and direct it right after
avengers endgame but that's not gonna
happen like that's just a joke
because they're still taking a huge
break from doing big studio movies and
they're in the middle of their own
smaller projects right now the really
good thing about Marvel Studios at this
point is that their moviemaking machine
is so well-oiled and there's so much
support on the production side of things
that they don't really need a big-name
director to come in so I'm fine with
whoever they get to take over the movie
scott derrickson is still gonna stay on
as an executive producer through the
process so just remember what happened
when they parted ways with Edgar right
before the first MN movie they brought
in Peyton Reed at the last minute the
ambien movie was just fine he's like a
c-list character they released it right
after Avengers age of Ultron Doctor
Strange obviously is a much bigger much
more popular character than ant-man it
will be really funny though if they try
to get Sam Raimi to come back because he
has his roots in low-budget horror films
Evil Dead army of Darkness dragged me to
hell
he also did a small indie franchise
called Spider Man back in the day he
also does really great work when he has
a good script so I totally don't blame
him for the mess that spider-man 3
turned into that was mostly the studio's
fault in Sony for forcing too many
villains into the movie right now
they're casting male and female main
villains and an african-american male
main character who might wind up being
dr. voodoo they even referenced dr.
voodoo in the first Doctor Strange movie
when Kai Caelius assaults the sanctum
and kills that guy that's actually the
older brother of dr. voodoo in the MCU
so we knew they were probably going to
introduce him at some point during the
Doctor Strange franchise it was just a
question of when it was going to happen
the male villain that they're casting I
think we all believe is going to be the
nightmare main villain character the
female villain though is a bit of an
interesting idea because we have Scarlet
Witch showing up in the movie as
full-blown comic book level Chaos magic
Scarlet Witch they also have to have a
female villain with parody to her power
level and besides say like the Phoenix
force and Jean Grey there aren't that
many female villains that Marvel has
that are as powerful as comic books
Scarlet Witch best guesses right now are
that it's either a brand new character
someone that they just create for the
purposes of the film or it winds up
being full-blown enchantress just
because she's a character that they have
not done yet they'll start shooting the
movie in the spring they'll release the
Doctor Strange 2 trailer sometime end of
November early December like they always
do for their May
movies every single year the reason why
they're releasing one division early
like they just announced hey you're
getting episodes early later this year
is probably because Scarlet Witch is
gonna show up in the Doctor Strange 2
trailer looking very different being
full-blown Chaos magic Scarlet Witch and
they want fans to understand what's
happened to her since the end of
Avengers endgame and why she's become so
powerful Marvel is also implying that
Loki is going to appear during Doctor
Strange too in some way seriously 2020
is actually gonna be a really good year
but 2021 is going to be off the chain in
terms of the content that everyone is
releasing not just Marvel everyone else
too so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you'll see all
the videos when I post them they're also
releasing the first venom Morbius
trailer on Monday so of course I'll do a
video for that too now everyone click
here to learn about Batman himself
Christian Bale showing up during Thor
for love and thunder and click here for
all those other brand new Doctor Strange
2 videos with Kevin Feige talking about
the movie thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]